[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: All
right, good morning.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Thank
you all for coming.
My name is Bradley Horowitz.
I am vice president of photos
and sharing here at Google.
And it's my pleasure to
welcome Luvvie Ajayi with us
this morning.
You all know Luvvie.
[CHEERING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to do a
super-brief introduction,
because I actually want
her to tell her story.
You all know Luvvie.
I have to confess,
a week ago I didn't.
But a good mutual
friend Lisa Stone
invited me to host this talk.
And so I went into a crash
course on learning about Luvvie
and why she is so prominent
in the blogging space.
And so I've spent that last
week getting to know her work.
And I'm super excited and, as I
shared in the invite, somewhat
nervous to be up here.
Because she tells it like it is.
[LAUGHTER]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
And it's pretty
clear I'm part of the problem.
So with that--
[LAUGHTER]
Luvvie, please--
let's welcome her.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
LUVVIE AJAYI: Hello!
That's hilarious.
[LAUGHING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Well, thank you.
Thank you for coming.
I know you're bouncing
around the whole country.
And we're glad you had a
chance to stop at Google.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Had to do it.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Have
you ever been here before?
LUVVIE AJAYI: No, this is my
first time on Google's campus.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Oh, well I hope
you get a chance to meet
people and look around.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I heard about
the epic slide you guys have.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
We have slides.
We have weird bikes.
We have food.
We'll treat you right.
It's going to be fun.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
So I want to start-- I think
most people here know it,
but for posterity and for the
videotape, tell us your story.
I mean, who are you?
How did you get to this chair?
LUVVIE AJAYI: By being a
professional troublemaker.
That's how I got to this chair.
I'm a writer.
I'm a speaker.
I'm a techie.
And I have been
blogging for 13 years.
I started blogging in 2003.
I was in college, and I was
peer-pressured into doing it,
because my friends were like,
you should start a web blog.
And I was like, OK.
So I went to Xanga.com
and started a web--
and I started a blog.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's not
Zingo, that's Xanga, right?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Xanga, OK?
Remember Xanga, like next to
Friendster and everything?
And I start blogging.
I was talking about college
life and all my randomness
and shenanigans and who I
was beefing with that day--
nothing interesting.
And basically I have my
college career chronicled,
which for good and all bad.
I read it, and I was
like, this is awful.
When I graduated from
college, I deleted that blog,
and I was like, I'm going
to start something new.
And I go to Blogspot,
fire up this new blog,
called it Luvvi's Random Rants.
And I was talking about all
things pop culture, television,
anything I felt like talking
about, but not myself anymore.
So that's how blogging
for me started.
And it basically took
on a life of its own.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
And you were born
in Africa, grew up in Chicago.
Tell us that story.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
So I was born in Nigeria.
And when I was nine, we moved--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Are you got shouting
for Nigeria or Chicago?
LUVVIE AJAYI: [LAUGHING]
Right, yes-- Nigeria.
So we moved to Chicago
when I was nine.
Nobody told me we were moving.
I thought we were
going on vacation.
[LAUGHTER]
And then I started school,
and I was like, oh, this
means we're staying.
Oh.
And it was a big
culture shock for me,
because I went from
never having to be
the new girl, like
my best friend was
the niece of the person who
owned the private school I went
to.
I'd been going to that
school since I was two.
So walking in a room and seeing
people who didn't look like me
and having to reintroduce
myself and basically
take on a new persona was
a huge shock to my system.
But, yeah, I had
this accent, too.
Well, no, not this
accent, actually.
I had a major Nigerian accent.
And I end up having
to-- I lost it
consciously by
mimicking my classmates
and like trying to repeat
what they were saying
and how they were saying it.
And then by high school
my accent was mostly gone.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Right.
She thinks it's gone.
Anyway--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Right!
[LAUGHTER]
Right.
You're right.
No, I hear it.
I'm super Nigerian, yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So do you think
that experience of sort of being
a transplant at nine years old
and being different
informs some of who you are
and your ability to
stand outside of things
and tell it like it is?
Is that part of why you're you?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Well, yeah.
So the tell-it-like-it-is-ness
that is me is my Nigerian-ness
in its true essence.
Like Nigerians, we're not a
great filtering people, OK?
We're not the ones
who are like, oh,
let me make sure I coat it
in all types of nice things.
We just say what we feel.
Like if you come like
my family dinner,
we spend the whole time
laughing at each other.
Like somebody will
walk in wearing
a sweater that's not cute--
[LAUGHTER]
--and somebody will always be
like, why do you have that on?
It's just how we function.
And in my writing, my
writing is essentially
who I am in real life in print.
Because I want people who know
me to read my work and be like,
OK, I actually hear her voice.
That's exactly her.
So how I write very much
translates to who I am.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's
interesting, and in your youth
from like nine
through high school
and things like that, were
you extroverted, class clown?
Like before in the
pre-blogging, pre-college years,
what was that like for you?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I have been
the class clown forever.
This person that you see is
who I was in high school.
I still have the same friends
that I did in high school.
And we were just a
goofy group of people.
We'll be in the hallway
just acting the fool
or playing spades
in the lunchroom
and just spend all
the time laughing.
And basically my
group of friends
are a really good
reflection of who I am.
Like you think I'm funny?
You come to brunch
with us, and you'll
be in tears, because none of
them have behavior or sense.
So it's just how I've been.
And being able to have it
translate to my writing
has been great,
because literally I
have these friends who
have known me for 20 years,
and people are like, oh,
how did you find your voice?
And I was like, do you see them?
That's me.
So it's not even a matter of
me having to find my voice.
It's me just growing it up.
Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So you went
to University of Illinois.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And I love
how she drops like 13 years,
like that's a long time in
tech and stuff like that.
LUVVIE AJAYI: It is!
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Way before you
got there, the web browser was
invented there.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Internet Explorer.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yes.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah, Mosaic.
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's
our claim to fame.
We're very proud of
that in Illinois, yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: My wife
went to school there, too.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Oh, yeah.
It's one of the things they tell
you when you go to orientation.
And they're like,
at Illinois, we
invented-- I was like,
impressive, I will come here,
yes.
[LAUGHTER]
This has changed
everything for me.
I must be here, yes.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And you got
into blogging while at college.
And so do you think
that's how you had access?
Like how did you
come to do that?
LUVVIE AJAYI: So I've
always liked computers.
I took computer-type
classes in school.
I was a person who actually
took an Excel class for fun.
So for me, I've always kind
of seen the value of computers
and all these types of software.
But I was also the person who
started infusing social media
into the work that I was doing.
Like I've been an early
adopter of most platforms.
And blogging was
just another thing
that I was kind of
an early adopter at.
Because when I started
blogging, it was just
playing on the internet.
But I was doing it because
I thought it was fun.
How I've been approaching
technology since,
I have to go to the
library to get my e-mail.
My first e-mail account
was a Hotmail account.
[LAUGHING] And I think it
was like vetvet@hotmail.
[LAUGHING] But then we had AOL.
So I've seen the evolution
of the internet grow,
and it's been really cool.
But I've always
found it valuable.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So that first phase,
you said you were sort
of blogging your college
experience, but then you
deleted the whole thing.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Do
you still have a copy?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I do.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK.
LUVVIE AJAYI: In
its Comic Sans font.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So do we.
We've got that in Google cache.
LUVVIE AJAYI: No!
[LAUGHING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
No, I'm just kidding.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Right, like, no!
No, like I had Comic
Sans font and everything.
And it was like--
it was just awful.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And it's
not up online right now?
LUVVIE AJAYI: No.
I think I actually was
like, OK, legit, delete it.
But before I deleted the
blog, I like copied and pasted
every single post
into a Word document.
And the Word document
is giant, because it's
three years of me in college
being a fool, being like,
oh, this is my roommate.
I didn't really
like her that time.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So
that's interesting,
because you're so out there
and so vulnerable and honest
about things.
Have you posted things
that you regret or go
back and delete or edit?
Like what's it like
having that out there?
Because these days, once
you put something out there,
it's out there.
LUVVIE AJAYI: It's out there.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Well,
so here's the thing
is about blogging
for so long, the good
and the bad thing is it
chronicles your growth
as a human being and as somebody
who thinks about the world.
And so things there are
things that I wrote in 2009
that I would never write
today because I vehemently
disagree with myself.
I'm like, no, that was wrong.
You shouldn't.
But some of those
things, I keep it up
to remind myself of
where I came from
and who I was in that moment.
And I like even thinking about
high school essays that I won,
I won like two major essay
contests in high school
writing an essay
on whether people
should receive reparations.
And my stance was no,
you didn't do that.
Why do you get reparations?
And I won an essay contest.
And I read the essay,
and I was like, god,
that's terrible-- no.
But it's really
good to still have
the record of who you were.
Because you see how you've
grown, how you've changed,
how your thought has changed.
College changed
everything about politics
and how I look at
the world at large.
So who I was before college is
completely different from who I
am now in terms of my beliefs.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: And I
guess how much of what
you do do you do for
yourself, and how
much do you do for others?
It sounds like it was
a little bit of both.
LUVVIE AJAYI: A
little bit of both,
but I try to do most of
it for myself. [LAUGHING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
I think that's why
you're so appealing, actually.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Well, because
my whole thing is, OK, one,
I'm not writing in
an echo chamber.
So the idea that I'm just
writing for myself is false.
But I am a writer
because if I don't write,
the words kind of stay with me.
So like I'm the
person who is taking
a nap on the plane
writing blog posts, too,
at the same time, which
is completely weird.
But I wake up with an entire
post in my head already,
and I'm just like, ah, OK, cool.
So in that way, I'm
writing for myself.
But also I'm writing for people
to consume it and hopefully
change hearts and minds.
Because I'm also not trying to
write to preach to the choir
all the time.
Because it's like at that
point, what's the point?
So it's a combination.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So you're
an early technology adopter,
early-on on blogspot,
early with blogging.
Are you keeping up?
Like where are you at on
vlogging, Snapchat, Instagram,
Twitter?
Like are there enough hours
in the day to sort of--
LUVVIE AJAYI: No, there are
not enough hours in the day.
And I am officially feeling
like the oldie in tech.
Because--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Well, I mean 13 years--
LUVVIE AJAYI: 13 years--
come on-- veteran.
[LAUGHING] But there are certain
platforms I cannot get with,
even though I've tried, and
I'm a digital strategist,
and I can see the value in them.
But me personally, me,
myself, and I personally, I
have a trouble infusing
it into my day.
Snapchat is one of them.
I have tried, you guys.
Snapchat-- so here's
the thing that I
have a problem with
Generation Millennia
and Generation Social Media,
which I'm a very firm part of,
is we feel like everything
we do is interesting.
And it's not.
[LAUGHTER]
So like people all spend
all day on Snapchat
telling you exactly
what they did
in every moment of their day.
And I'll log into
Snapchat, and I'll just
be like, you know what?
Today's the day I'm
going to give it a try.
And I'm going to scroll through.
And people are
walking to the bus
like, yes, I'm walking
to the bus stop.
OK.
And?
And then the filters are
killing me softly, you guys.
Like the filters, the flower
filter, the face-- I'm just
like, why does everybody look
like a cartoon right now?
So I have a Snapshot account,
but I log into it like once
a month.
And I think I've
Snapchatted twice total.
And I do actually have
a Snapchattable life,
because I'm in
these random rooms.
I call myself Forrest Gump.
I do all these
interesting things.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That's you?
LUVVIE AJAYI: [LAUGHING]
Right, like can you believe it?
But it's like, catch me on
Instagram, catch me on Twitter.
I'm on there.
Catch me on Facebook.
To add Snapchat to it to
catch a moment-by-moment thing
of my day is just a lot.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
And what about vlogging
or YouTube or--?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I have
actively rejected YouTube.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Why?
AUDIENCE: [GASPS]
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yup, I have.
Yup, I said it.
[LAUGHING] At Google.
[LAUGHING] I've made it a
point not to be on YouTube,
because I don't like the
community on YouTube.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
Well, this is something
I wanted to talk about.
Because social media
has tons of es.
It's part of why you're
here today and part of why
we know about you.
But it's also a place where
there is a lot of hate
and a lot of misinformation
and filter bubble.
And I want to talk
about that experience.
So we're heartbroken you've
rejected YouTube wholesale.
Most of the people who aren't
here today are working on that
and fixing it as we speak.
So we'd like you to give it
a try tomorrow or next week.
LUVVIE AJAYI: [LAUGHING] Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: But
what is your experience,
both good and bad?
Have you been trolled?
Have you been doxxed?
Have you been harmed by
social media personally?
And how should we as owners
of some of the services
that people use think
about what we can do?
Without getting into
censorship and repressing
people's feelings, how do
we create safe environments
for people?
LUVVIE AJAYI: OK, so my
decision to not do YouTube
has been, one, because
I hate editing stuff.
And again, I don't want
it to just be me talking--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Oh,
so you're lazy is the--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Lazy
is part of it.
Oh, absolutely.
But then the second part is I
hate the community on there,
because that community
is so full of hate.
Because at one point, it
was where you can actually
comment anonymously.
And what that spurs
is keyboard courage,
people who decide that since
they are a number in a system,
they can say whatever they
want, as opposed to it
being attached to their names.
So a lot of my friends are
YouTube stars and like people
who built their
following on YouTube,
like Franchesca Ramsey.
And I used to see
the comments they
would get all day, every day,
and to avoid the comments, they
would have to sit
there moderating it,
either themselves, which,
of course, triggers
all types of trauma.
Or they just actively
just be just be
like, I threw up a video,
I just never go back
into my comments section.
And for me, the
power of the internet
is connecting with people.
And I think that's
really important.
So I was like, you know what?
I'm a writer.
I prefer to write.
I'll be writing.
Y'all catch me there.
I don't want to do videos yet.
And I know YouTube started
fixing some of that.
I was never really recruited
to come back into the fold.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Well,
consider this an invitation.
LUVVIE AJAYI: An invitation
to come back into the fold?
Like I was using my Vimeo
channel, because I was like,
you know what?
I need to store some
video somewhere.
So I just didn't feel like
YouTube was the place.
Now, in terms of the
hate online and trolling,
so as a black woman--
well, as a woman is one,
as a black person is
another, as a black woman is
another-- the type of feedback
that we get on social media
is completely different
from everyone else.
So this was tested out
by people on Twitter,
actually, where
they did like a week
where they exchanged avatars.
So black women and
white men decided
to do this experiment
and exchange avatars
and see how the
difference in your avatar
affects how the
responses you get are.
And the white men who
had the black women
avatars for the
week were stunned
by the type of vitriol
they got for simple stuff
that they were saying.
For me as a side-eye sorceress
and a professional shader--
[LAUGHTER]
--I am lucky to not
receive some of the hate
that a lot of people get.
Because here's the thing.
I can beat you at that game.
Like I've spent all
my life being shady.
I can do this.
But I've been fortunate--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: The trolls are
afraid of you, is the problem.
LUVVIE AJAYI: The trolls
don't come at me as much
as they come at other people.
I will say that.
But one thing that I've loved
about my social media platforms
is people saying that
my community reflects
me, which is king compliment.
No matter where I
am on the internet,
I like to keep my spaces clear,
free of hate, and as a space
you can get in a public domain.
So my audience is also very
protective of the spaces
that I've created.
So if any type of
hate creeps through,
they handle it before
I even get there.
Because they understand that
this is one of the few places
you can go and actually
read the comments.
So how everyone else tells
you, never read the comments,
you want to read the comments
on my posts on my Facebook,
on my Twitter, on
anywhere that I am.
Because my audience is super
smart, super thoughtful,
and they've managed to maintain
a space that is actually good.
And it shows the best
of humanity, as opposed
to the rest of the internet,
which kind of shows awfulness.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So I
want to talk about filter
bubble, this concept.
You mentioned you don't just
like to preach to the choir,
right?
That's part of what you do.
But you also want to
reach people and change
people's minds.
This morning my wife
showed me a site
called FriendsWhoLikeTrump.com.
I don't know if
you've seen this.
But it actually exposes
your Facebook friends
who have actually liked Trump.
So I did a bit of
unfriending this morning.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Amen.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I'm proud to
say out of 1,000 or so friends,
I had eight, and
most of whom I either
didn't know who
they were or hadn't
spoken to them in 30 years.
I did grow up in
Michigan, which can have
little pockets of purple state.
But I did ask myself, am
I perpetuating this filter
bubble?
Is my feed now going
to be filled with stuff
that I already believe?
And am I not getting exposure?
Should I have had more
curiosity, like why on earth
would people I know support
a candidate who let's
just say I can't get behind?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Who
is a walking Cheeto?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
[LAUGHING] You can say it.
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: The worst.
OK, so here's the thing.
I tell people off jump.
Like my social media
platforms are not democracies.
They're dictatorships.
I will delete.
I will block.
I'll report as spam at will, OK?
And feel no guilt about it.
Because here's the thing.
That's not a filter I really
even want to be a part of,
to be like clearing your space
of Trump supporters, that
is one of the few things
that I draw the line.
It's like, oh, we can't
be friends, off jump, OK?
Like there's no
conversation here.
You support him?
Because supporting him means
you support and tolerate
hate and misogyny and
Islamophobia and anti-Semitism
and anti-woman.
And it's just anti
everything that
is not straight, white male.
And it's a problem.
So you deleting
those people, I don't
think it's necessarily
creating a filter bubble,
because here's the thing.
What do you learn from them
besides what you already know,
which is that hate does
exist in the world?
And even educated people who are
somewhat sensible and logical
can still tolerate awful things
in people who perpetuate that.
And I don't have the
capacity to even do that.
I am not a mediator.
I'm not the person you walk
up to just like, oh, my god,
let me see both sides.
Oh, no, I'm very much
biased about everything.
So yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I've heard
you talk about the difference
between journalism and writing.
You consider yourself a writer.
And it sort of speaks to this
biased-and-proud attitude
you have.
Can you talk a little
bit-- at Google,
we have things like Google News.
And even our search
results, we work
very hard to make them fair.
Talk about journalism
versus writing and maybe not
only the role you
have in that spectrum,
but where should Google sit?
Should we be opinionated, or--?
LUVVIE AJAYI: So
I do call myself
a writer and not a journalist.
Because I feel like
as a journalist,
you do have to
maintain some level
of like, what, objectivity?
And just be like, I'm not
always going to choose sides.
I don't know how to do that.
I'm the person who can't
write-- I can't write anything
but op-eds.
But they'll be fact-based.
So for me, I give myself
the responsibility
of making sure I'm
double-checking to make
sure I'm not passing
on fake news,
making sure that my opinion
is based on some fact
that I heard.
So that is important.
As a company, I
understand if Google
wants to maintain
like neutral ground.
So it shows both sides.
But then as a person
of opinion and I
think as a leader in
all things, Google
might need to one
day step up and say,
actually, this is the
lane that we pick.
Like if somebody
goes into Google
and wants to find a way
to join a hate group,
I feel like it should
be a little more
difficult for them
to find it, to find
that type of information.
Because essentially, you can
serve up information to them
on a platter.
And be like, just because we're
being impartial, what does that
do for the world?
And how does that impact
the betterness of the world?
And I think Google
is a company that
cares about that in some way.
So to make it that easy I feel
like I would be a mistake.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yep.
The people that aren't
working on YouTube
are thinking about
that right now.
[LAUGHTER]
But you look at
Google, it's pretty
clear we have a very
diverse workforce,
just looking out
at the audience.
I'm kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: He's like
[INAUDIBLE] [LAUGHING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I wish
this was representative
of our workforce.
Unfortunately,
this is a biased--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Shout-out
to Bradley for that!
[LAUGHING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: But
we are working on it.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I think
we're very much in a listening
and learning mode.
And as we try to address this,
like any advice on that front?
How do we actually
create-- the people who
are creating these products,
how can they more represent
the world and the audiences?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Google
and other tech companies
have got to start trying harder,
even harder than you are now.
[APPLAUSE]
Because here's the
thing, is I feel
like every company
needs to reflect
the world as it is for the
greater good of that company,
too.
Because more diverse
voices in the room,
your products are going
to be even better.
Because you're getting all
types of people being like,
have you thought about this?
No, that doesn't work.
What about this?
And I think it's in
your best interest
to get you some more
color, get you some more
people of different backgrounds
who can be in a room
and be like, oh, OK,
this is what I think,
and then not gets shut out by
their coworkers who are white.
[APPLAUSE]
Like even recently I
was reading an article
about how the women in the
White House in the Obama
administration have
formed like this Voltron
where when they're in meetings,
if one woman says an idea,
another woman repeats it,
and then somebody else
repeats it who's a woman just so
the idea is not given to a man.
Because we've been
in enough rooms
where we say something,
and everyone is like, eh.
And then the dude says it,
and they're like, great idea.
You're like, word, like I
didn't just say that four times?
So in that type of a way, I
think tech companies need to,
one, it's not even
necessarily them
having a conscious
bias to be like,
I'm just only going
to hire white people.
That's not it.
We tend to engage
with people who
are in close proximity
with us, people
who look like us who are
like in our immediate circle.
So those are the
people we end up
telling they have
job opportunities,
and those are the people who
end up basically applying.
What needs to happen is the
very pointed and focused attempt
to go outside of that proximity.
Like go to places
where you haven't been.
Ask people who don't look
like the executive team.
And honestly, get some black
people on your executive team,
too.
Y'all need that.
[APPLAUSE]
But I think it's a process
that needs to start now.
And people need to be very
prioritizing about it.
Like it shouldn't be one of
those things that's like, if it
happens, it happens.
It needs to be like a focus.
Because in, what,
2030 or 2040, there's
going to be no ethnic
majority in the country.
So it behooves Google
and Facebook and Twitter
and all of them,
Apple, like everybody
needs to start making
it a point to find--
And it's not a quota system.
It's not you being like, well,
we need four more black people,
we need four
Latinos, four Asians.
No.
You want to find people
who are qualified,
and they're out there.
Like people say, I can't
find black techies.
I can't find Latino techies.
There are Twitter
lists of people
who have 500-- that says
Black Techies at the top.
So we're out here.
We exist.
And we--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We do have
some competence in search.
So we ought to be--
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: I think so, OK?
Like Google is like the search
king of the entire universe,
not even Earth.
There are probably
aliens using Google.
So you have no excuse not
to be able to find and find
the people who are good.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
Cool.
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: He's like--
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
So in the spirit
of putting us on the spot--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah!
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
--me in particular,
I want to share something
you recently wrote.
"Another day, another hashtag.
White people, you
gotta get to work now
about the killings of black
people by law enforcement."
You say, "White people,
I'm talking to you.
This is your problem to fix.
Y'all got some work to do,
because this system that
y'all keep on privileging from,
you've got to help us dismantle
it.
Because those of us who are
black and brown, we have tried.
You created this robot, and
it is yours to deactivate.
My skin folk don't
have the passcode.
This is your monster to slay."
LUVVIE AJAYI: Word.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So for those of us that
agree, where do we start?
How do we become better at
helping slay the monster?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah, you
gotta slay the dragon, man.
It's a multi-step process.
And I think it comes from--
we can change policy all day,
every day.
But if policies change but
the hearts of the people who
are in these spaces to enforce
it don't, nothing happens.
So the real deep belief that
it is the job of white people
to fix racism because if we
could have fixed it by now,
we would have done it.
And we have tried.
So one, listening-- I've seen
enough conversations where
people are like, here's how I
felt when this issue happened.
And somebody walks in
being like, well, maybe
you're just looking
at it the wrong way.
I was telling you
how I felt about it,
but here you are
trying to argue me down
about my opinion
and my feelings,
which feelings are valid.
So one, listening.
Two, when these things happen,
a lot of times people will say,
I don't know what else
to say at this point.
It's getting even worse.
If you don't know what to
say, amplify the voices
of those who do, so
lending your platform
to people who are able to say,
this is how it's affected me.
This is what I
think we need to do.
So lending your platforms
to black and brown voices.
I also think people need
to put their money where
their hearts are.
People have money.
Silicon Valley has money.
At the minimum, donate to
anti-racist organizations
and people who are actively
doing the work to fix it,
people who need the
resources and who
need to get in the room.
That's important.
And then, some of us have all
these platforms to speak up.
Speak up.
Use it.
Because here's the thing.
I don't have a job.
I could say something.
Nobody's going to be like,
Luvvie, you're fired.
So it is in my best interest to
use my voice, because I don't
have anything to lose there.
And also one thing
that we need to do,
because it's like
right here, it's
the lowest common denominator,
is our friends and our family
members.
When they say hateful
things about people
who are not in our group
who are marginalized,
we have to say something.
And you know what
we do when we see
some stupid stuff in Facebook.
We'll like scroll
past and roll our eyes
and be like, oh, I hate the
fact that they just said that.
But we never confront it.
So that person thinks it's OK.
So even across the
dinner table when
somebody is saying something
hateful, in that moment,
you have to let them know
you can't tolerate it.
Because if you let it happen and
you say nothing, you're saying
it is fine.
It should happen just like that.
[SIGHING] Huffing and puffing
is not enough-- actively
being like, hey, that's
actually not an OK statement,
here's why you're wrong.
And after I wrote
that piece, I actually
got a lot of notes
in the two weeks
afterwards from people
who had been like,
I've actually taken that on.
One of my friends
e-mailed me and said
her husband's father always says
something racist every time.
And he just scrolls past it
and shakes his head in Facebook
and he's like, oh,
that irritates me.
After I wrote that
piece, his father
put some like racist
joke up, and he sends him
a three-paragraph email
about how that was not OK.
And she's like, I just
want to say thank you
because he told
me to let you know
that the reason he did that
was because he read your piece.
And he realized that he can't
be quiet anymore about it.
So even small
things-- we don't all
have to start nonprofit
organizations.
We don't have to be
the ones marching.
But we can do stuff
in our everyday lives
that actually can move the
needle just a little bit.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Yeah.
That was some amazing
practical advice.
I wasn't actually expecting that
much actionable stuff that I
think all of us can do in
this room and in this company
and in this world.
I know for me, one
of the challenges
was sort of coming to grips
with how much I had to learn.
And for me, a lot
of it was really
in taking this
unconscious bias training,
where I sort of walked
in there sleepwalking,
like not expecting to be rattled
or shaken by what happened.
But what was really
revealed was a lot
of the societal
conditioning that
had sort of-- even
me, a good guy, who's
trying to be part
of the solution,
there's a lot of deep
work we have to do.
It was very humbling
in a lot of ways.
It's sort of like,
the last thing
I wanted to do once
that part of me
was out there was sort
of get up and pretend
to be part of the
solution when I understood
I was part of the problem.
And I think the answer
is sort of both.
Like when I first started
really concentrating my team
on some issues around
diversity and inclusion,
I reached out to
a friend of mine
who's been doing this work
for really 30-plus years,
and she was sort of like,
welcome to the conversation.
There are professionals.
There are people who have
spent careers and lifetimes
thinking about these problems.
And I know a lot
of us are waking up
for the moment for
the first time,
but it's important
to sort of plug in.
And I think your suggestion
even to just give
resource, where that's money,
time, technology platforms,
to those people who
are professionals
and have actually spent a
lifetime thinking about some
of these things is really
important for those of us that
are quickly catching up.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I mean, I
think part of the thing
is when you start
talking about race
and you start talking about
responsibility of white people,
a lot of times
people feel accused,
like they are personally the
ones who are being racist.
But here's the thing that
people have to understand
is privilege, no
matter what it is
your privilege is-- like I
have a bunch of privileges.
I have class privilege.
I have sexual
orientation privilege.
I have gender identity
privilege, religion privilege.
So there's certain
things that I need
to understand that in all
these systems, because I'm
a part of it and I benefit from
it, I am a part of the problem.
And it's not a Luvvie,
you did this one thing
that was wrong to this person.
It's you are part of the system,
that even though you might not
have contributed personally to,
you still have to help fix it.
Because you're in a position
where you can influence stuff.
I can be in a room
where I am one
of the-- I am going to assume
that most people in the room
are Christians.
And that gives me a safe space
to talk about my religion.
But if somebody is
there who is Muslim
and they feel like
they're not safe
because they're in this space,
it's my job as somebody who
is of the majority
group to make them feel
comfortable and welcome,
like I can't just be like,
well, it's not my fault
because I didn't say nothing
bad about Muslims today, so--
[LAUGHTER]
That ain't got
nothing to do with me.
No.
So I think it's really important
to use privileges to basically
help marginalized people.
And also, part of what we
start learning about privilege
and our space in the world,
the space that we take up
in the world, is that
we are lucky, one.
We've done nothing to be in
these spaces a lot of times.
Like I was born Christian.
I've never been poor.
So for me, it's like, OK, I
can't take credit for that.
I can't be like, well,
you know, I earned it.
I didn't.
It gave me a lot of
things that I worked from.
But also, you have to
unlearn a lot of things.
Like you realize that
we've been programmed
so well that the
process of fixing it
means you have to unlearn stuff,
as in dump that out your head,
that is not what the
world is really about.
And that's the really hard
part of unlearning everything
you've known for how many years
you've been on this Earth.
So you just kind of
got to commit to it.
It's not going to be easy.
It's a drop-kick to your
ego when you realize
you're part of the problem.
It is.
It's like, damn, I didn't
know I was that person.
You are.
Now, now that you know that
you are that person, how
do you not become that person?
How do you make sure
somebody else is not
hurt by your personhood?
And one thing that I actually
wrote about in my book
was-- has anyone heard about
the Privilege Exercise?
Oh!
I feel like every company in
Silicon Valley-- actually,
every company in general
needs to make this happen.
So the Privilege
Exercise changed my life
and how I looked at the world.
And I was a counseling
center paraprofessional
when I was in college, trained
to be a peer counselor.
But the whole first semester
was us learning about who we are
and the space we take up.
And literally, we spent
a whole six months
talking about ourselves and
who we are and unpacking it.
So one thing we did was
the Privilege Exercise.
So everyone starts
in the same line, OK?
You start in same line.
And they make a statement.
You either step
forward or step back.
So a statement would
be something like,
step forward if you've never
had to worry about somebody
mispronouncing your name.
People step forward.
Step back if you've
sometimes worried about where
your next meal is coming from.
Somebody steps back.
Step up if you can marry
the person you love.
So it's a series of questions.
Sometimes it's
like 20 questions.
Sometimes it's 50.
At the end of the Privilege
Exercise, they say,
stop and look around
the room and see
where you are in
relation to other people.
So sometimes I found
myself higher to the front
than I actually
imagined I would be.
And some of my classmates in
the back, and I was like, wow,
you're behind me?
And it gives you the perspective
of understanding like, OK.
So the Privilege
Exercise, you get
to actually get to
figure out, wow,
I'm behind a lot of people.
I never would have thought that.
Or I'm actually way luckier
than I thought I was.
And it teaches you about who
the people you're around are
and also some of
their struggles.
Because some of my
classmates who were white
girls were behind me.
And I was like, I wonder why.
So we got to unpack it.
I feel like it's really
important for companies
to do this.
Because give your
employees a chance
to understand where they are in
the world and what they fit in.
Because sometimes in these
rooms, the people of color,
the people who are
different, LGBT people,
might not feel
like they have room
to even step up and
say something to you,
because they might
gets shut down.
And the people who are
saying things never
understand that they take up
a lot of room all the time
and don't give room
for other people.
So it's a way to kind of
recalibrate and get folks
to understand that I might
need to either shut up more,
or I need to step up more, or
I need to advocate for more
people, or I need to be the
one that's like advocating
for myself more.
I think it would
be good for Google
to do it for a couple of people.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Wow.
That's a great exercise.
[APPLAUSE]
What I want to do-- we've got a
couple mics up here, and we do
want to make this interactive.
So as you think
of your questions,
while you're doing that,
I want to invite Luvvie,
if you're willing
and open to it,
maybe read a section
of your book,
do a little reading for us.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes,
I can do a reading.
And I'm trying to figure out,
should I do one for-- OK,
so my book is broken up into
four sections-- Life, Culture,
Social Media, and Fame.
Now, each section-- so the Life
is like full of shenanigans.
The culture section, I talk
about like racism, homophobia,
religion.
Social Media section,
I'm talking about,
I Hate Your Hashtag Abuse.
[LAUGHTER]
Facebook is My Favorite Soap
Opera, Dumbed-Down News,
How to Succeed at
Business Failure,
Real Gs Move in Silence.
So what section would
you like me to read from?
AUDIENCE: Culture.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Culture.
All right, let's do it.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: That
was pretty unanimous.
LUVVIE AJAYI: All right.
So I actually just
basically give you
a rundown in the-- let's see.
I think I'll do religion.
Yeah.
I have a chapter on
rape culture in here.
I'll just be-- I went in.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm trying to see what
I haven't touched on.
Privilege, racism-- OK, so
I wrote a piece of my Racism
chapter while-- it was like
a week after the Charleston
shooting, and that
night, a church had been
set on fire in South Carolina.
And I was moved to write because
I was just like so angry.
"In Charleston, South Carolina,
a small bible study group
was praying to the Lord on an
otherwise uneventful Wednesday
at Emanuel AME Church,
the oldest black church
in the South.
A white supremacist
walked in, pretending
to want to pray with them,
and then pulled a gun out
and murdered nine black
worshipers in cold blood.
It was invasion of
a place of refuge,
a violation of a
literal safe space,
and definitive proof
that there is still
a war on black
people in America.
Nowhere is safe for us.
And the work that has been done
over half a century to get us
closer to equality
has regressed,
and it feels like we're
back to where we started.
And now another one of
our churches is burning.
And this was 2005.
America is treating
black people like vermin,
and it's hard not to feel like
we're unwanted and unsafe.
It's open season
on black people,
and that was not
some lone gunman
who walked into Emmanuel AME.
He represents the
ongoing commitment
to keep us in our place,
a violent reminder
that we are not safe.
We're not safe in the streets,
in our homes, at the park,
or at church.
And I'm fucked up about it,
because this was supposed
to be history, not the present.
And I feel the anger
from the top of my head
as it reverberates
down to my toes.
This rage makes my skin burn.
I feel the fire in my bones.
This is racism at its worst.
It's ugly, demented, and vile.
It also permeates
every fiber of what
the United States is made of.
And it's what's built the
foundation of this country.
It's truly exhausting,
and I'm not sure
if I'm thankful for the
undeniable proof that racism
is still around us or
wishful for the days
when we could be
tricked into thinking
things were not so bad.
But racism is not just random
individuals burning churches
and black people being
gunned down the streets.
It is a system of
oppression that
is so deep and
omnipresent that it
seeps into every single
aspect of our lives.
And it is as American as apple
pie drizzled with canned cheese
topped with French fries.
The red stripes on the
flag are really the blood
of black and brown people.
In many centuries after
the country's creation,
these stains still
have not faded.
And let's pause here to
say that racism in America
is stupid as hell.
Racism and prejudice
anywhere is dumber,
but it makes no sense,
because it's just absurd.
The United States of
America is a country
founded on the labor
and literal bodies
of black and brown
people, who were minding
their own business when
white folks came forth
to kill and exploit them.
This is a place that was
discovered by a dude who
didn't know how to read a map.
So he just showed up on some
shore, thought he was in India,
and then proceeds to
plant a flag and go ta-da!
No.
What Christopher Columbus
needed was a compass and a clue
for being an
aggressively mediocre.
But he has a federal
holiday in his honor.
He showed up on
someone else's property
and claimed it as his because
he didn't know what it was.
This country started off all
the way wrong and continued
in the same fashion."
I feel like Chris
needed Google Maps, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
Like, you in the
wrong place, sir.
This is not India.
Hot mess.
And we celebrate him.
We celebrate him.
This is so American.
"And then Chris slaughtered
Native Americans,
wiping out whole tribes,
pillaging the people,
and called it Thanksgiving.
And to add to the
mess, the dude bros
realized they didn't
even have the ability
to build dope shit on their
own, so they went to Africa
and captured black people
and then brought them here
to be their slaves after killing
millions on the journey here.
Because if you want to
out-terrible yourself,
you stuff millions of
human beings inside ships,
refuse to feed them, let
them lie in their own filth,
and then let them die in droves.
So not only did you
steal someone else's home
and then kill them
when they showed
you kindness, you went
elsewhere and then did some more
stealing, this time
of actual people.
And you forced them to
come to your stolen house
to do your work for you.
I mean, you're welcome for
this 'too long didn't read'
version of imperialism
in America,
but this is why I
should teach, OK?
I wouldn't do any worse
than current textbooks,
like the ones in Texas that
use the word 'workers' instead
of 'slaves.' In the section
about the Transatlantic Slave
Trade, they called them
'workers,' as if black people
were at a career fair in Africa
where we submitted resumes
and asked to be beaten and
starved and have our families
broken in exchange for a
journey across the ocean with no
money."
Like this is not LinkedIn.
Why-- we're not "workers," OK?
"So my point is that the
United States does not
have a legitimate history
of integrity and fairness.
It's been run by villains that
make Disney's look like saints.
Racism is not a
byproduct as much
as it's the foundational
stock in the American soup,
and this is why black
people are still
fighting to be recognized
in our full humanity.
The success of the country has
been based on our oppression,
so of course it is
forever fresh out of damns
to give about black lives.
And we are left to
grieve for those
we've lost to the grubby
hands of white supremacy.
We rage about the
perpetual cycle of mourning
we find ourselves in.
And we wonder what we need to do
to be secure in our own skins."
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
Powerful ideas, but
also powerful writing.
That was really beautiful.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Thank you.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK,
questions from you.
We have two mics up there.
Googlers aren't shy, usually.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Right.
Don't be shy.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We
have a lot of practice.
We have this event called TGIF,
which we hold on Thursday,
of course.
And we have these mics up
there, and people are always
asking our founders
and leadership
pretty much anything,
telling it like it is.
It is a great tradition.
So questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So first, queen, just want
to honor you and thank you
for existing and being here to
share and help lift us all up.
Also want to acknowledge I
wish this room was completely
full, because you deserve
all of the 60,000 Googlers
listening to you.
So there's that.
But I actually do
have a question.
My question is, as
Google works on trying
to continue to
diversify, so we actually
have people working here that
reflect the people we serve
around the world, how can
we also change the culture
so people are allowing
us to be ourselves?
I feel like what
you said earlier
about speaking
straight, not padding
things with a lot of sugar,
it really resonated with me.
I think one of the things
I find hardest to be here
is that I need to
put so much sugar
on the front and the back
end that I can't even
call it a sugar sandwich.
It's like a cake.
So how can we as a
people and as allies
help people understand that
it's not the same lens?
You can't bring in all these
different cultures, Africans,
African Americans,
Latinos, Filipinos,
anyone who is not
white, and expect
us to act white in a company
that is majority white.
LUVVIE AJAYI: So
communication is cultural.
That's one thing that I think a
lot of people of color struggle
with in companies like this.
Communication is cultural.
For me, I'm a very
direct person.
If I need to send you an email,
I'm going to be like, hey,
what's up?
So here's what I need from you.
People prefer, hey, so, I
hope your day was going well.
I was wondering if you could
possibly do this for me.
Who has that time?
Why I gotta like layer it
with 1,500-- can I just get
to the point?
And then people
are like, well, you
were kind of short in e-mail.
Because I asked you a
question as opposed to like
went through a three-paragraph
diatribe about, how you doing,
girl?
Wander in.
Girl, how was your weekend?
Honestly, people
need to understand
that different communication
skills and different ways
people talk in email is not
an affront to you as a person.
Like if I was to send you a
two-paragraph email, because I
am on the go, that's not
me being short with you.
That's me being on the go.
And I think a lot
of black people
end up being
on-the-go types style.
And their coworkers end up
being like, I felt like that
was very short of you.
Honestly, there needs to be
a little bit more-- people
need to get our their feelings.
That's important.
Get out your feelings
as a coworker.
Like if somebody sends you an
email, and then they're like,
I felt kind of short.
You can ask them.
Be like, hey, are you OK?
As opposed to like I hear a
lot of passive-aggressive stuff
happening.
Get out your feelings.
If I send you a two-sentence
email because I need something,
it doesn't mean I don't want
to know how well you're doing.
It means in that
moment, it's quick.
So I think Google might
want to do some more
different communication styles.
Ooh, you know one
thing that helps?
OK, so there's
this website called
16personalities.com allows
you to do a personality test.
And if you work
closely with any team,
have everybody on the team
do this personality test.
It will break it down and be
like, OK-- so it will tell you
exactly how that person who
sits next to you communicates.
They're the person
who's always on the go.
They're very direct.
It will even break it
down to the commander.
There's the commander, the
diplomat, the mediator.
That helps, too, for
you to understand
how your coworkers like
to receive information,
how they pass it on, too.
It is not a front to you.
Learn who you're
working next to.
As opposed to people having
to like temper everything
and put them in sugar cakes.
Who has time, you guys?
Come on.
Let's do more work
and send less e-mails.
That's also important.
Stop emailing people
for everything.
Jesus.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I think
part of the problem,
we're all commanders.
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: But what happens
if one commander is like,
oh, man, I just got commanded
too hard? [LAUGHING]
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
OK, another question.
AUDIENCE: Sure,
so, Luvvie, again,
just to mimic Sarah,
some of her comments,
just thank you for coming
here and making time for us.
LUVVIE AJAYI: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: So my name is Howard.
And I'd be really
curious to hear about--
so there's various
domains of types of work
that we could be
doing to kind of fight
institutionalized racism
and kind of address
the racial climate in
general in this country.
And so you can send e-mails.
You can protest.
You can strategize
about policy change.
You can mentor.
You can kind of just be even
just a shoulder for folks
to cry on and mourn.
And so there's always
diversity, different things
that we could be doing, right?
And I think society
kind of conditions
us to maybe want to do some
things more than others.
Because maybe some
of these things
might be more risky
or challenging.
So for example, for
many of us, maybe,
protesting and getting
pepper-sprayed in the eyes
is kind of like, ah, I
don't want to do that.
But like maybe if you say like I
can volunteer at Oakland Impact
Hub, sure, I'll do that.
That sounds reasonable, right?
Given the problems
that we have, given
how minimal amount of the
workers there are for us
to address the
problems, what would you
say is like the most important
prioritized domain of type
of work that we really
need to focus on in order
to get shit done, right?
Like there's a ton of
different things we can do,
and I love the approach of
like, oh, just like weigh
your talents and gifts, and
whatever you're really good at,
that's what you should do.
Eh--
LUVVIE AJAYI: I think
there's no one thing to do.
It needs to be a
multilayered approach.
Knowing what you're good at
and where you can fit in,
though, makes a difference.
So I already know
I'm not going to be
the person on the front
line getting pepper-sprayed.
I'm not about that life.
I give props to
the people who are.
My job in this
movement, if anything,
is to tell the stories.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: I'm
not good at that, either.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Right.
I'm just not built for that.
[LAUGHTER]
Which means like the people who
do that are actively putting
their bodies on the line.
And for them, we owe them to
make sure they're supported
and the work that they're
doing is not in vain.
Because if they're standing
on these front lines getting
pepper-sprayed, it
better be for a reason.
And we better be
working to make sure
that doesn't keep
happening to them.
So it means if your
job is to write policy,
you are the policy person.
Yes, make sure that people
who are in Capitol Hill
are changing laws.
If your job is to tell
stories, tell these stories
and make sure people
are understanding
what's happening in
these streets, what's
really happening, not what
the media is reporting.
If your job is-- if you just
have so much money you don't
know what to do with
it, give it to some
of these people who can then
turn that money into something
concrete.
So it really comes
down to, you don't
have to force yourself
to do something
that's outside the realm of
your interests or your passion.
What you're good at,
whatever that is,
you can find a way that
it's going to help.
So again, find what it is,
where you fit in in that place
and do it and kick
ass in that way.
So I already know I'm
not built for the life
of being on front lines.
I'm little, OK?
No.
Like I wouldn't even make it.
I am not built for it.
So yeah, you have to
support in wherever way you
know how, as opposed to
you being like, well,
I have to be the
person protesting.
No, you don't.
There are amazing people, like
Black Youth Project 100, which
I have to give a shout-out to.
If you want to know
some organizations who
are doing amazing work, who are
making sure the Chicago Police
Department is actually
being held accountable,
there's Black Youth Project 100.
There's Dream Defenders.
There Assata's Daughters.
So these are people
who you can be
giving your money to who will
show where the money's going.
Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
OK, yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Good morning.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
When I saw on the calendar
you were going to be here,
I got super excited,
because my book club
has been talking about your
book for the last month.
So thank you for being here.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My question to
you is, how do you get over
that first step of fear?
I feel like people have voices.
They want to say something.
But as you alluded
to earlier, maybe
you don't want to
say at work, you
worry about losing
your job, or changing
in your world or your
friends becoming different.
And how do you get
over that sense of fear
that you have that you feel like
you should be saying something,
you want to, but you're
worried about what you're going
to let go of in the process?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Fear is one
of those things that--
fear itself will cripple you
from doing whatever it is.
And then when you do
it and push past it,
you understand that you were
more afraid of the thing
than how it really was.
So here's the thing.
There are often times
when I write a piece
that I'll be like, oh,
my, gosh, am I sure
I want to publish this?
And I'll sit on it.
I'll hesitate on it.
But every single
time I press Publish,
the response I get
lets me know, yes,
you were supposed to do that.
Because here's the thing.
As a person who's
thinking about that thing
that you want to talk
about that's scary,
you're probably not the only
person thinking about it.
You are probably amongst
people who are also
afraid to say the same thing.
But sometimes all it needs is
that one person to cut through
to be like, hey, I feel
like this is wrong,
or I feel like
this is-- and then
you will see the people
who are like, [SIGH]
finally somebody said.
OK, I can back her up now.
I think it just comes
down to pushing past it.
If it's important
enough for you, say it.
You can put it in the
sugar cake if that
makes it fine in that
meeting, but making sure
that point is made, because
a lot of times, people
do the things that they don't
even realize are harmful.
Or they don't understand
what damage it's doing.
And they just need to be
called on it to be like,
oh, I didn't even know.
OK, you're right.
You might have to
be the scapegoat.
You just be like,
I'm going to say it.
I'm going to say it,
because that's how I feel.
This is a valid thing to do.
And I feel like
it would actually
push this conversation forward.
You just gotta do it.
It's not going to
be like less scary.
You're gonna have to be like,
oh, I'm scared shitless.
But I'm gonna do it anyway.
OK, guys, I don't think
this is a good idea.
And even just doing that, you
just have to power through it.
AUDIENCE: I like it.
Thank you.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: OK, I can
see we have more questions.
I think this is the way
we're going to do this.
Unfortunately,
we're out of time.
And I know that
there are people who
need to set up this for lunch.
This is also our lunch room.
So we'll take one more question.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I'm here.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
And she's here.
That's what I was
going to say, is
we're going to feed her and
show her a Google bike--
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: Important things.
Priorities.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: --giver
her a little bit of a tour.
So those of you who want
to, I think it's OK with you
if we have a little
private time with you
by the side of the
stage afterwards.
But we'll do one
more formal question,
and then we'll hand
this room back over.
So one more question, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I first wanted to say thank you.
I'm not quite sure what
I'm thanking you for,
but thank you.
And then I'm not sure if I
have a question or a statement,
but two quick things--
first you talked
about diversity and Google.
I received a question from
a friend of mine who said,
you work at Google.
How did you get that job?
And I was just absolutely
amazed, because I said,
I applied.
[LAUGHTER]
And I will say that I'm a
high school dropout, never
been to college, never
taken any technical courses,
left high school
in the 11th grade.
But I have enough confidence to
say, I'm good, I'm intelligent.
I applied.
But I think it's a
statement, is that I
think Google needs to give
people permission to apply.
I think we need to do more
reaching out to people and say,
hey, I don't care
if you're this,
I don't care if you're that.
Apply.
We can't just wait for
people to come to us.
Because they'll
say, that's Google.
They don't want me.
I'm not good enough.
So any advice that you have for
Google and all the people who
are working on diversity, I
think that would be great.
Because everybody goes, how
did you get a job there?
And I would love
for people that feel
that they are confident enough
to at least look, at least try,
because all you
can be told is no.
And the other thing is, you
were talking about racism,
and I have been just feeling
helpless and watching all
of the protests and getting
excited about the Justice
Department saying, we're going
to take this shooting of this
innocent or not-so-innocent
black person,
and then it turns out that
the Justice Department
doesn't-- the case
doesn't go through.
They're not charged.
And I'm a ranter, which
I might be doing now
instead of asking a question.
But I have been posting
on Facebook about the fact
that people sit on the
courthouse steps and say,
this is not going to work.
We have to do something
about it, and we see Beyonce,
and we see Snoop
Dogg, and we see
Al Sharpton, all of these
activists, and they're saying,
this is not good.
We have to stop this.
But then they step
back, and they go back
to their everyday
lives, because they
have this feeling
of helplessness,
and they don't know
what to do next.
So a couple of weeks ago, I
gathered a bunch of friends
that I work with from
a design company,
and we did this great,
big like ideation,
brainstorm on what we could do.
Because in my eyes, it has
to start within the police
department, right?
It can't be the lawyers.
It can't be the
district attorneys.
It has to be the
police department
to go past that
blue line of silence
and start telling the
other police officers,
I'm not going to testify on
your behalf, you were wrong,
you shouldn't have done that.
And I feel like it has
to start from within.
But I don't know
what to do next.
We've got a bunch of ideations.
We talked about redesigning
the pullover and all
of these things,
but we're now trying
to figure out how to
reach other people
and how to use our
voices and make
this this great, big
movement that says,
it has to start from within
the police department, right?
I watched an episode of-- god,
I can't remember the show.
Taye Diggs is in it.
I can't remember the name of
it, but he shot a black guy.
They couldn't find the gun,
but his partner told him
the next day, I talked to the
captain, and I backed you up.
And it wasn't true.
And that was just an
example of what happens.
Instead of them saying,
no, he was wrong
and I'm not going
to stand by him.
So we're trying to figure
out ways to do that.
Any advice so that I can
take it to the next step
where it's not just a
meeting of people who go back
to their normal lives
and say, oh, we met,
but I don't know
what to do next.
LUVVIE AJAYI: The first
question of how-- so there
is something that feels very
inaccessible about working
at Google.
It feels like aspiration as
opposed to a reachable thing.
So a lot of people don't even
know it's an option for them.
Because they just think
people who work at Google
happen to get like a
magic golden ticket,
and they showed up, and
they're like, oh, my god,
you work at Google?
It sounds like a legend,
like, oh, man, it's
like Charlie Wonka's
chocolate factory.
Because I mean, this place
is a magic, like, what?
You have slides.
[LAUGHTER]
I think Google needs to do
a better job of making sure
that people understand that
they actually have a chance
to work at Google,
and they're not
just like engineers
who get coding things,
and they're like, oh,
you can be a coder.
You actually have people
do social things at Google.
I think Google needs to actually
make it more accessible.
So whether you have people going
to more colleges who are like,
yo, you don't have to
be hyper-geek engineer
to work at Google.
You can actually apply for
like the events coordinator
job or the admin assistant job.
Or if you are in STEM, you can
apply for a job in strategy,
in coding.
So I'm not sure what
outreach you guys are doing,
but you might want to do that.
I know y'all don't throw a
post on Indeed or LinkedIn,
but that might help.
It actually would help if people
knew that they could get a job
at Google and it wasn't some
like pie-in-the-sky thing.
AUDIENCE: Permission to apply.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: We
are doing a lot of that.
I want to just give a
shout-out to the team.
I actually met with
them yesterday.
And we have a lot of
work to do, but there
are people at
Google-- part of it
is just making sure we are
where people are, right?
Like Mountain View is a
little bit like Disneyland
in a lot of ways.
And we have a great,
big world out there,
and Google is fortunate
enough to have
offices in a lot of places.
And we have to do a lot more
outreach, a lot more inviting,
a lot more welcoming.
And I know that there are
teams of people at Google
who are working on that.
LUVVIE AJAYI: And I also
have to give Google props,
because here's the thing.
Like I know you're constantly
being told to do better,
because you should.
But the fact that your
leadership is taking it on
as an actual thing,
not just because you
are getting your wigs
gnashed about it, matters.
I think it's really
good to see people
at the top who are
saying like, OK,
help us figure out what to do.
We realize we need to do better,
so we're going to do better.
So I have to say props for
that, because the trickle effect
is real, right?
Because if leadership
didn't care,
nothing is going to change.
So I just want to say props
to you for that, Bradley.
BRADLEY HOROWITZ:
OK, on that note--
[LAUGHTER]
LUVVIE AJAYI: Did he just blush?
BRADLEY HOROWITZ: So on behalf
of everyone here and Google,
thank you, not only for
coming and visiting us,
but the work you do every day
of putting yourself out there.
It makes a difference,
and we're very grateful.
Thank you.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Thank
you for having me.
It's so cool.
[APPLAUSE]